Estie saying, "Um, I'm just hardcore doxing anyone I can find
information on now." So now the doxes are getting >> to
hear this play out in like a live VC. >> He's running.
He ran.
I dude I I can't help it, man. She said I think it's because
I read his DMs about how he likes to walk around in public with
a butt plug a few days a week and I can't take him seriously
after that. I just think that's totally fair. Like do you have
to take somebody's political opin opinion seriously if they have
to steal their wife's butt plug? They can't even get their own.
>> It's pretty weird. >> Pretty deranged, huh? >> That's
saying nothing of the weird diaper fetish,
which is Destiny was taunting the people, doxing people around
him way before I ever turned against him. Way before I ever had
any reason to hate the guy. Nick, he defin knows who who it is.
No, Auggie. I don't believe Auggie was on that stream. Was Auggie
on that stream? Thought it was Turkey Tom and Nick at one of
Oh, did they really go for dinner at one of Destiny's College
talks? Yeah, Auggie was not on the Jan 6 stream.
Anyway, he just said Nick. Okay,
we got Nick on Destiny today.
Oh,
possibly for this. Yeah, let's check it out real quick. And then
I'll pull up Nick's full statement from his stream today as well.
>> Whatever ongoing narrative is, I feel bad for you. Uh,
there's one thing I did want to show, and this is probably the
main thing that's kind of annoyed me in this entire situation,
is just hearing the the newest, most recent clip of Destiny for
some reason. Really >> Oh, interesting, dude. Spray, I
need I I should talk to Auggie about this. I'll ask him about
it when he comes on. I don't know if It's funny you mentioned
Flamco. I talked about this earlier. Oh, what's up?
>> Hey, how's it going, man? >> Uh, let me not super
loud. I'm live on kick right now as well, so I'm just making
sure your audio isn't like just blasting my stream. There we
go. >> Pretty sure we're good. Test test test. >> Good,
good, good. >> So, you watched my stream, dude. What did
you think? >> Uh, it was good. I mean, I It was one of
those things where it's like, yep. Yeah. I I feel bad when my
content is all just agreeing with the person, but it's like >> dude.
The I think the >> It's hard not to watch me and just agree,
you know? I'm especially in this situation, right? like >> well
actually a little bit recently. Okay. I've watched a couple stream
I've watched your last two streams. I was just about to tell
one of my chatters about the Flamco stream. I need those DMs,
dude. I was like this guy literally has like 15 different Reddit
accounts and every single time he goes to like r/christianity
and r/bdm personals or something or BDSM personals and like starts
messaging women
>> arguing Christianity. >> You and you and Tipster
like both of you guys are like give me the DMs. It's on Kiwi
Farms, dude. Like apparently everyone that covered >> Yeah.
Yeah. Everyone that did everyone that covered Flamingco didn't
put in any work like actually looking into like what he was saying
on there. I read all the DMs. They're insane. Like they are so
nuts. He's like messaging girls. He's like, "I know you're still
in school, but does this age gap bother you?" And stuff like
that. And then he's also messaging other people about like >> uh
diaper fetishes and stuff like that. It's crazy [__]
bro. That's nuts. >> Crazy. But on the topic of uh Willie
Mac, you know, I've listen, I need to take cover. I need to take
hostage. Like the community has turned, bro. I'm I'm in a sinking
ship. I've been uh I've been left I've been thrown out to the
wolves, bro. I'm scared. >> Dude, I I get where you're
coming from. It's It's crazy when you know you're right and people
will criticize you and then they'll disappear the second you
say, "Well, come come throw your criticisms at me in voice."
They just all disappear. It's like so weird. Oh, dude. The gaslighting
on Twitter has been insane. Even in my chat tonight, there was
like one moment where I was live and the whole chat was like,
"You're fuck." And I don't know if they're just saying that just
like, you know, own me or something like that, right? But like,
no, the gaslighting on this whole topic is just absolutely insane.
Willie Mac's positions are like indefensible. And that's like
completely obvious to anyone with a functioning [__]
brain. I mean, he has just gone off the deep end. He's a liar.
He's malicious. I mean, he really showed his true colors uh tonight
yesterday. Yeah, >> dude. I thought it was really funny
that he um he's blaming you for not showing the Queen clip >> when
you're responding to his criticisms of me and he doesn't mention
Queen at all, right? Like why would you even think the Queen
like you know it's relevant. You say it's like a part that it's
a part of it. You like explain the context, but he doesn't complain
about Queen and you're you're criticizing his yeah his hypocrisy
for criticizing me, right? You're not even saying like he can't
be mad. You're just saying your comments about Jtock and saying
you got docks by him or or that he's amplifying your docs are
stupid given your conduct. >> That's like the only argument.
>> I mean, it's stupid because like >> I didn't understand
to be fair. I didn't understand his interpretation of the Queenman
clip when I did my first stream like two weeks ago. I didn't
know that his interpretation of Queman's clip is that Queman
is like dog whistling his support for Willie Max shows docs.
I didn't know that Willie was that he read from that clip. But
now that I know that that's his argument, it's even easier to
debunk because that's [__] insane. Like it's actually
just I I don't even have to spend time debunking it. Like he
sits he plays Queenman's clip and he's like, "Oh, well somebody
donated like Max Striker Films donated and said that oh like
uh orders taken orders." Yeah. Orders received blah blah blah.
And Queman laughs and says, "No, that's not my position." But
because he laughed,
that means that Queman was saying, "Wink wink nudge nudge. I
support that donation and I support people attacking him." It
is [__] in It is Keel's. It is beyond Keelles here.
I feel like Keel's had a more solid argument against Kiwi Farms
than Willie does right now. >> Um, yeah. Well, and I'm
glad you called it out at the beginning. He is like, "Yes, that's
true. I've been tweeting a couple times recently that Destiny
is Keeful 2.0 No, cuz Destiny's the where this originates, right?
Will he just takes Destiny's points and repeats them uncritically
like
propaganda against you guys? You Destiny is [__]
Destiny is really you guys over and Willie is repeating that
[__] on his own platform. And it's actually more
damaging when Willie repeats it because Destiny's reputation
is so tarnished that when Destiny says, most people can dismiss
it as like, oh, you're like the criminal guy, right? When Willie
says it, Willie is actually respected. Willie has never been
in a controversy where people can dismiss something that Willie
says because Willie is like insane. Nobody views Willie as insane.
So when Willie repeats Destiny's propaganda, he's uh validating
it on a level that even Destiny can't do. Uh I would say that's
true. I would say I don't know. I So I all my Twitter followers
are in that sphere, the Twitch politics sphere, right? So people
still give Destiny a lot of weight there because they're so I
guess for the to the wider internet I don't really see that but
I it's >> Destiny has his fan base Destiny has his fan
base that's true but most people outside of like the DGG corner
I would assume I hope so think Destiny is a complete nutcase
right they don't think that about >> so you'd hope so
>> I'd hope so I feel him that way >> I think Dest
is the biggest piece of scum on the internet right now I think
He's like competing with everybody. Like it's it's totally insane
that he would have gone after Keeles and now he's like actually
doxing is awesome and also like I'm going to just basically accuse
these people of doxing and also
>> [__] nothing he says has any
weight to it. He is just a vindictive
neurotic
out loser. That's all he [__] is.
>> he will justify anything he weaponizes against other
people against them. I mean, you even see like even when Destiny's
like attacking people uh that have nothing to do with any of
this drama. Like you can say what you want about like Nick Fuentes
for instance, right? But when Destiny is sitting there being
like, "Oh, you know, Nick Fuentes like lies about me and says
that I tried to deplatform him." When that's exactly what he
tried to do back in 2019, even situations like that, it's like
that's bull. There's clips of you reporting his Twitch account.
He's a liar. He's a chronic liar. Uh he's a narcissist. He's
a drug addict. He's an unstable
He's a piece of [__] to the people around him. I
really hate Destiny.
I really hate him. And I hate that people are so stupid that
they still buy his to this day. You have no excuses after Pixie.
Before then, maybe you did, right? But after Pixie, that was
the moment where we all collectively should have realized, you
know, uh, Destiny is a maniac and he should go down. >> Yeah.
I mean, the funny thing or not funny, but the the other thing
about the Pixie thing is like people say it's just the pixie
thing. That's like the one credible thing, but like Molina and
Molina and there's this Curio Cactus girl on Twitter as well.
They're in those same leaks and they both said no without like
there was no consent there, right? And I understand that. I understand
people are like, "Oh, well, they haven't pursued a legal case,
so I don't know how to take it seriously." But like, there are
five or six women who all have the same complaint who have all
said he sent this stuff non-conensually. It's like starting to
become a Cosby situation, right? Where it's like, okay, I can
understand like you maybe say one of them's like malicious, but
all of them, literally all of them, >> that seems unlikely.
No, >> I mean, it's just so [__] funny to me.
Like he does this like multiple times and people still sit there
and I don't think Destie understood that he could get in trouble
for this up until this year. Like I feel like he
can just do this. >> Wait, did you not did you not know
that? Um Hold on. I got these I got these clips loaded up all
the time. >> hold on. Are you in the uh are you in the
call right now? Can you join the presentation? You have any way
to >> Yeah, let me uh pull it up on stream. One second.
>> So I I can just say it as well.
In January of 2021 during the Bob 7 thing, apparently Destiny
had been sending Molina, who's his wife at the time, to women
that she hadn't approved of. So non-consensually sending her
two random girls. And when Molina found out about that, she chastised
him in 2021. So he doesn't even have the argument of like, oh,
I didn't realize this was that bad. No, he admits in this clip,
in this section of this clip, oh yeah, I thought it was okay,
but apparently it's not okay. I need to get explicit consent
before I do that. Right. >> I can play it for you. It's
like it's crazy that there's so many people who are like, "Oh,
well, he's getting a second chance now." It's like, "No, this
is like chance five." >> A long time ago.
Okay, so long time ago, obviously, new people had conversation
about a few girls, like, "Oh, cool." Like, we record videos like
send people like it's fun. So, we do this. Um, I kind of like
have like my little archive of like material that I'll send to
people if I want to. Um, there were girls that I talked to um
past that that I'd send stuff of like either me or me and Molina.
And Molina talked to me and she was like, "Hey, um if you're
going to send any videos to um new girls who we haven't talked
about, like let me know that first." Um because she wanted to
be careful. I was like, "Okay, sure. That was fine." I didn't
think about it at the time cuz I think it matter, but um yeah,
sure. So, I thought about that. So, so like I don't think he
gets any benefit of the doubt on like, "Oh, well, I didn't really
know it was that bad actually." Right. >> Yeah. No, that's
fair. I didn't watch the Bob Seven drama. That was a whole that
I just avoided. So, I've never seen that clip before. But yeah,
that's uh that's crazy. So he knows and he's just like, "Well,
whatever. Who gives a I mean, he's a sociopath." Yeah. >> Yeah.
Just doesn't care about other people anyway. >> I mean,
I could I could attack him a lot harder. People in your chat
are like, "Is Auggie okay right now?" I'm fired up. I just responded
to Willie Mack. I've got all the talking points like in my head
right now, just floating around. I'm fired up, man. I've been
attacked. I've been attacked and I'm uh I'm ready to fight back.
I I I think
>> the best criticism of that video or sorry no the best
praise of that video is that the garbage arguments and like horrible
clip chimping the horrible way it's put together like it's so
thick that it's hard to actually go through it. You're pausing
like every 5 seconds. Every 5 or 10 seconds you have to pause
and go well that's complete bull and it's like hard to keep >> it's
hard to keep coherence with the video. I was worried when I was
going to do the because I was only originally I was going to
do the stream and then cover other [__] but then
I was like, "No, I just need to get this over with and just respond
now and just get it done, right?" And I was worried that I'm
only going to be really just watching 10 minutes of a video,
so my stream's just going to be like 40 minutes long or something
like that, right? And every word that he says, I can just go
on like a 20 minute tirade about how stupid it is. It's crazy.
>> Yeah. Oh, dude. Yeah. Hey, I noticed you were going
off a lot of the time. Spray just made a great point as well.
He sandwiches it between two like bad empanada Hassan segments.
So like it totally whitewashes that middle segment, right? For
people who don't know, they're like, "Yeah, I hate bad empanada.
Yeah, I know that guy's crazy. Oh, these guys are also crazy.
Oh yeah, of course I hate bad empanada." It's like h it's like
>> the video is deliberately the video is deliberately
designed to just be like it is designed for you to watch it and
not know anything about you or me or Queman and you just watch
it and you're just like wow cuz that's exactly the comments like
the the level of intelligence in the comments that I'm getting
when people are like giving me or people are saying like I can't
believe you're a Hassan orderer now. I can't believe that you
uh you back up Queen's like doxing
tirades or whatever, right? Like you're really like you've fallen
off this hard. Like I know you left the internet, but you've
fallen off this hard to where you're supporting doxy now against
Willie, one of your friends. Like that's like the level of intelligence.
Even like my straw man of like the criticism that I'm getting,
even my straw men are more intelligent than the actual criticism
that I'm getting. I'm actually like forming more coherent arguments
than the ones that I'm actually receiving in my inbox. Like they
are just crazy. And the reason why they're crazy is because this
video is designed for morons to look at it and just go like,
"Uh-huh." Yeah. You nod your head to it. No critical thinking
required. You just see it and you're just like,
is augie
a moron." Not even like Augie's a but you you watch it. You watch
the video and you think Auggie is a [__] that does
no stream prep that doesn't know what he's talking about because
the deceptively the deceptive way that he edits that video. He
splices all these clips of me saying like, "What are you talking
about? What are you doing?" to kind of paint the narrative that
I just went live one day and talked out of my [__]
It's like no, I'm responding to you saying stupid and I'm going,
"What are you saying?" But Willie edits me saying, "What are
you saying?" as if I'm He puts it into like a montage to demonstrate
that I'm some sort of clueless moronus
that doesn't know what I'm He says that. He's like a so confused
this whole stream. I'm like, "No, you're editing it to make it
look like I'm stupid. Come on now." Like, be honest with that.
And that's why I can't accept that this video was made like reasonably.
I can't accept that. This video was made to me over and I'm not
going to take that lightly. I did Nicholas say that explicitly
that he said like
did you watch his comments yet? Did you see his whole like set
of commentary on this from his stream or were you live when it
was going on? >> I saw like the two minutes that he spent
>> going over it or whatever, right? I mean, look, I people
all night long have been wanting me to go after Nick and I'm
It's like dude,
>> this is where I'm going to cut, >> but it's like
I'm not trying to go after >> Yeah, I don't need to turn
on your friend or anything. I was more saying it was funny that
I think he said something like I told I told Willie not to go
back after these people, right? And in response to that, he published
this video. It was like it it seemed like Nick was criticizing
him saying like, "Dude, I said don't do this and then like in
reaction to me giving you good advice, you were just like you."
It seemed like that was his comment to me. But maybe I I do need
to go back and see it again because I'm not sure I read it >> Like
Nick was like more Willie for like ignoring his advice. Yeah.
Will Nick was like giving him the advice, right? Because it's
it's one thing to say you don't want to engage with these people,
but then because Nick is smart. Nick never like really mentions
Queen by name like almost ever because he doesn't want to fight
with Queenman, right? But he drop he drops like little nuggets
here and there like kind of taking these little sides swipes.
But Willie wants to go and like post on his channel. And then
when you're posting on your channel, you want to go after these
people. Then you deserve to have you deserve to be questioned,
right? If you're going to post a video, if you're going to say
this is my opinion, then you should have to defend criticism
against that. You shouldn't be able to just drop a video and
say, "No, no, no. I'm not taking any criticism." >> It's
like, dude, they want to sit there and act like, "Oh, well, I'm
just going to ignore these people and move on." That would be
fine if you actually ignored these people and moved on. But you're
not ignoring these people. Willy's taking snipes at you and Queman
all the time on Twitter. Then he makes this video on you, uh,
Queen and me, right? So he's totally willing to engage, but only
on a platform with a narrative that he can control. He's not
willing to engage directly, but he's fine like making a full
video, a fulllength video, an edited, you know, documentary basically
on us on his own channel, that's when he's okay with engaging.
But engaging onetoone, h that that's uh it's not worth my time.
But it is worth my time to make a video. Okay, dude. Sure. I
I also think it's funny how transparent he is that like when
he wants to stop the only thing he wants to have stop is for
people to say he's like Destiny adjacent or Destiny sweeper or
affiliated with Destiny. He like literally says why are you propagating
the narrative that got me doxed and it's like dude what like
you saying he's a what is it not a double agent but um controlled
opposition right? He's like that's the bad thing. It's like what?
>> That's the crazy part too. It's like we're now like
semi partially responsible for him ultimately getting docks because
what like we have criticisms of him, you know. Yeah.
If you say that he's like if he if you even say that he likes
Destiny even a little bit, you know, you're tying him in with
Destiny and then all these malicious people that are trying to
like over Destiny once they redirect their attention to him,
we're responsible for that because we're putting them in that
camp. I I don't agree with that at all. I mean, that was just
crazy, too. I mean, I don't know, dude. It's just the whole thing
is just like he's obviously very hurt. He's hurt by your coverage.
He's hurt by Queenman's coverage. Um, I think he was hurt by
my coverage and he's lashing out and I understand. Look, I'm
not a monster. I get that. I get the fact that he got doxed and
he got over genuinely by bad empanada. bad empanada did horrible
[__] to him and I can accept him being a little bit
emotional or not reacting
100% like logically. >> If he just come out and said my
bad guys, I'd be like, "Oh yeah, that's
>> He can't say that. He can't say that though. He's like
so locked into his own line of thinking and that's what got him
into the situation in the first place. you know, you guys gave
him a little bit of [__] But because he was so locked
into his own thinking, you know, he just dismissed what everything
you guys said as just garbage
and you know, he got mad because you guys kept pressing
and he kept arguing and it just created a situation where he
got more and more furious the more you guys kept covering him.
And now we're at this stage of the game where he's perfectly
willing willing to smear us all as doc supporters or people that
are justifying his docs because ultimately he's pissed off at
criticism you guys levit against him six months ago. >> Dude,
it's it's crazy. And that just the the idea that like cuz this
is what Destiny does. It's like the same tactic. It is all like
a pure like petty personal grievance, but it's also the same
tactic where it's like I'm going to call you doxers and you know
what makes you not doxers? Uh if you stop criticizing me, if
you stop talking [__] about me, stop being mean to
me. Stop saying I'm like stop saying I'm sucking Destiny's dick
and then you know then I won't be getting doxed and then everything's
fine. It's like dude, how about you just post the proof? Are
you really not going to post the proof of Queen and doxing? Also,
oh man,
so many different things here. I want people to stop saying,
"Hey, Willie, can you post the proof?" No. Say, Willie, why are
you protecting the doctor that you know is in Queens community?
You said you know it. Why are you protecting that guy? Stop protecting
that guy. >> Out him. >> The [__] He
might be in other communities collecting information on >> Like,
are you really going to let this >> I want to know who
the doctors are and I want to ban them. You know what I mean?
I want to know who they are and I want to get rid of them. Right.
Everyone wants to do that here. You want to do that? Queen wants
to do that >> and Willy's not naming the names. And you
could say, "Well, maybe he's not naming the names because he
doesn't want to give attention to who they are." Well, he's giving
attention to bad epinota by making a whole video about them,
right? So, name the names. Expose the bad actors here so that
we can get rid of them. But instead, he's weaponizing, and I'll
say this, right? This might be a crazy take. I think he's weaponizing
his docks to go after people he doesn't like. >> I'm not
saying he's I'm not saying he's glad that he got doxed. I'm sure
he's not. But I am saying that now that he has been doxed, he
is perfectly willing to weaponize that information uh to go after
people that have been a pain in his ass beforehand.
>> Yeah, I think that's pretty clear that like there's
just no if he I mean if that weren't the case, he would have
posted any evidence. You know what the evidence is, right? like
like along the lines of what he would argue the evidence is is
stuff like well Queenman criticized somebody and then the Kiwi
Farms Dusty's Kiwi Farms thread posted their docs and it's like
okay but you understand that like the way that went down was
so they presented as if if as if like somebody went and found
that guy's information went to the effort of doxing them and
then posted it. But what actually happened was somebody saw like
some clip from Aquaman stream in that thread. They went wait
is this guy doxed? And then somebody went, "Oh yeah, like nine
months ago, that guy got doxed in this thread." Before any of
the Destiny dropped, way before that, right?
Way before that, he was doxed in that thread. And they just reposted
the same thing. But there are people who are like trying to perpetuate
a narrative that like, oh, there's this brand new movement to
like dox people who is critical of, which is insane, right? Well,
he's completely ignorant to the fact that like this community,
like the politics community online, whether it's left or right,
is one of the most vitrous uh is one of the most uh vicious places
on the internet. You know, we're talking about like most of this
content relates to like the Israel Palestine war. All these people
that are super hyperactivated
in this conflict, they're willing to do whatever the they want
to other people and it's literally life. Yeah. They openly do
it because it's literally like a life ordeath situation for them
even like just online like bad empanada is going after people
that are you know anti-Palestine or whatever. He he's literally
said like, "I want these people. I want them like insulted, fired,
blah blah blah, like slandered, smeared, and stuff like that."
Right? I feel like Willie has no grasp or no understanding of
just how vicious this community is. And so once he engages in
it, he gets doxed. He's acting surprised. He's like, "Well, I've
made videos on Logan Paul and I've never gotten docked, even
though Logan Paul's like a 20 million sub YouTuber." And it's
like, yeah, but dude, the people that follow Logan Paul and are
interested in like hating Logan Paul are not tied into this like
worldwide conflict that has so emotionally radicalized them to
the point that people that follow the Israel Palestine war have.
And that's not to say that it's okay, but understand like your
surroundings a little bit. You know what I mean? Like it's kind
of like walking into like a dark alleyway and you get and you're
like, damn, I didn't know this alleyway was so dangerous. especially
at night. And it's like, yeah,
the were you expecting? It's like walking into Compton and you
get
out or whatever, right? >> Yeah. Exactly. It's like maybe
that you're in a dangerous Maybe understand you're in a dangerous
area. And it's not to say that whatever happens to you when you
step inside that area is okay. But it is to say that like understand
like you're not just, you know, you're not in Disneyland, okay?
You're in a dark scary alley at night and you're probably going
to get
Okay. >> Uh I mean that could be true. I'd say
>> that is that a good comparison?
>> I would say it's like kind of a good comparison. The
Ethan Hassan and Dusty stuff, right? Like getting into that like
it seems pretty clear that Ben Empanado is going to go after
people. I don't I don't know. It It's up. I wish it weren't the
case. It's not Yeah. It doesn't make it okay. It's just like,
dude, I don't know why you're assuming it's Queenman when you've
got somebody who you're literally making the rest of the video
on who happily doxes people. Happily doxes people who have your
exact position and who take the exact side you do with like Ethan
Klein and this whole war against Assan.
You have like people who have motive and a demonstrated track
record and you're going to go, "Well, this other guy who like
has no demonstrated track record, I'm just going to blame him
with no evidence."
>> Yeah, it makes no sense. >> Why not? Because these
guys picked me off. They broke my brain eight months ago and
now I'm just desperate to get rid of them. That's why
>> we might have somebody who wants to join. Salty McNalty,
do you want to hop on the stream? You could hop on the stream
right now and get very, very, very mad.
We would love for you to hop on the stream. At this point, DG
from this community. >> No, somebody this guy just said,
"At this point, DG is a safe haven from my community." Apparently,
my tiny community that like grows by 10% whenever Destiny mentions
it on stream.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure. This guy's just uh he's going off. I would
love if he hopped on, but you know, soon as you call these people
out, they they kind of just disappear. >> You can do it
oneonone, too. Like, if you want to go at me, JC can mute. If
you want to go Jtock, I'll mute. It's not going to be like a
gang bang or something like that. >> Boom. Bang. Yeah,
there you go. But yeah, the people never want to they never want
to hop on. It's It's like such a to be to feel like you're just
totally right and people will never ever like come and just talk
about it. >> Yeah. I think it's cuz they want they want
to like misrepresent you in their mind if they if they come on
and talk you they'd have to like actually contend with the fact
that when when they're like you don't care at all that his wife
is dox and you go like no this obviously really up and I would
totally understand him crashing out over that >> a just
the appeals to emotion just got to end man it's so infuriating
it's like Willie Mack was like you're arguing in bad faith have
you considered that my wife and me and my wedding was about to
get attacked or whatever it's like I'm not for that like what
the [__] are you talking about, you know?
>> Yeah, I know. I know. >> It's like It's like if
I was doing this stream and it's like, "Have you considered that
I stubbed my toe this afternoon and I'm mad? I'm more mad than
usual. Let me just bring up some irrelevant detail to justify
my
>> But then to go make an edited video, doubling down on
that emotional outburst, right? Like straight up doubling down
on it. Not apologizing, being like, >> "It's fine to be
emotional. It's fine to be emotional. It's fine to not It's fine
not to respond to things logically the first time. I spur out
all the [__] time, but I do it in private, right?
And then I collect myself and I cover stuff, right? That that
it's completely human and natural for Willie to get doxed, for
his wedding to get attacked, for his wife to get attacked, and
for him to be emotional and to not respond to things 100% logically,
right? Obviously, >> but we're past that stage now. He's
shot, he wrote a video, he shot it, he edited it, he published
it, right? We're so beyond the point of like your emotions being
like an excuse that making that argument is just pointless. >> Yeah.
Oh, um, this is an excellent point from Salty McNelte. So, apparently
Kyla, Willie Mack, Steven's girlfriend, Willy Mack's wife. I
believe also there was Dan and Dan's family. I believe all of
those people except for Willie Mack and his wife were docs before
Qu before January 20th. Before Que and I, before I was against
Destiny, right? So, there's this there's this idea that my community
did this. As of the time those people were doxed, everybody but
I believe Willie Mack. I'll I'll double check this at some point.
I'm positive for Dan. I'm I'm pretty sure for Destiny's girlfriend
that these people were doxed before I was ever against Destiny.
I was still a part of this community, right? But I'm being blamed
for them as if me doing negative coverage on Destiny caused that
to happen. Which is Destiny was taunting the people, doxing people
around him way before I ever turned against him. way before I
ever had any reason to hate the guy or knew that I'd have any
reason to hate the guy. Yeah, hold on. JTO Gunnar Arc I
Hold on. He's This guy's linking me the um what do you call the
message here? Destiny saying um I'm just hardcore doxing anyone
I can find information on now. So now their doces are getting
posted. Yeah, he's hardcore
>> Well, dude, like you're saying like Destiny Dan got
doxed way before this. They declared like nuclear war on Twitch
and all the top political streamers on Twitch. Like obviously
that's going to draw a significant amount of negative attention
towards them. So that doesn't even like surprise me. >> Dan
left because of Destiny taunting the Muslim community. Dan left
the internet because he didn't want the heat of Destiny taunting
the Muslim community and then he came back and he's like doxing
people now. I don't know. It's >> Oh wow. He left the internet
based. >> Very weird.
>> Yeah. Let's go. >> Yeah. Took like a year off
quick. >> Leaving the internet is based. >> Can be.
Can be. Yeah. Yeah, I thought it was really weird for Willie
to start leaking those private calls, especially given the other
stuff that you leaked about your conversation with him. Like
I it feels just bizarre to me for him to leak details from that
call. I don't know what
him up especially [__] him up that hard and I'm going
to laugh so hard if he comes out with like a recording or something
like that, right? Cuz he was so nervous about me recording him.
You know what I mean? So if he comes out he's like, "Um, actually
I have the recording right here. Here's Auggie crying or something
like that." It's like, wow. So, you got upset at me for and I
don't think he recorded it, just to be clear. But if he did,
that would have been that would just be crazy to me on its own
because it's like, bro, what the you got so worried that I was
recording you, but then if you were recording it the whole time,
that would have just been crazy. But yeah, I don't know, man.
It's just such a
It's such a stupid situation. I'm curious to see like what the
fallout of this is going to be, but um yeah, I don't know. Well,
it it's like I would just hope that a lot of these people who
follow these content creators because they give them like sort
of moral advice and they criticize other people that they'd hold
them to the standards that those creators have have set. Right?
So like Nick's whole thing, I know you don't want to talk about
Nick, but I'll just talk about him. Nick's whole thing has been
like you have to criticize your own. You have to self police
your community because if you don't, you turn into the unhinged
lefty like trans community that just like argues that kids should
get hormones and [__] like you if you don't police
your own, you go crazy. And then it's like, okay, your friend
just your very close friend who you've been defending for months
and months and months just posted a video like clearly maliciously
lying about contemporaries of yours and another one of your friends.
I feel like that's I feel like it's time to police. If there
was a time to police, this is probably the time to police. Don't
even worry about commenting on it, though. I'm just kind of venting
a little bit. It's uh it's weird.
>> I mean, I I don't know. I already said like in my personal
opinion, I'd love to see his coverage on it and stuff like that,
but like I'm not trying to be in a I just don't want to be in
a position where it's like I think he should cover it because
I want him to like bail me out of this controversy or like fight
my battles for me or something like that. It's like I'm perfectly
capable of commenting on this stuff on my own. >> He can
do whatever the [__] he wants. And he called me to
be fair. He called me and he was like >> I'm not going
to cover this tomorrow. And I was like, "All right, like you
know, whatever. You do you." Yeah. Sorry, there's a guy in my
chat who's asked like a hundred times now. Did you have dinner
with Destiny at some point? Have you met Destiny in real life?
>> Yeah, I met Destiny. I uh I met Destiny. We had a We
didn't have dinner. We had breakfast at a a Waffle House.
>> It was the event he did. >> Yeah, he was debating
Elijah Schaefer and uh me and Turkey Tom and Flamingco were there
and Connor and it was very
>> Oh, cool. Damn. >> I mean, he was nice when I
met him. I don't have really anything interesting to say like
about that interaction, but yeah, this is back in like 2022.
>> Okay. Yeah, somebody I think somebody had said like,
oh, cuz Destiny had that clip where he he pretends to confuse
you and Nick, and it's like I'm pretty sure you're not confusing
him and Nick. Like I I understand Destiny like tries to play
stupid. Destiny joined uh like a private VC one night, maybe
a year ago, and it was it was when Bowax was crashing out about
Destiny, and Nick told him a whole bunch of stuff that Boax had
said in private about Destiny, like how he'd seethed about Destiny,
and and Destiny was so down to hear all of this stuff. It's like,
dude, you know who these people are. Why do you pretend you don't
know who all these people are? >> I don't know. Yeah, >> it's
it's weird. weird in response to that clip like a lot of people
are saying like I think Nick covered in he was like oh he's never
been a fan of Destiny. That's not true. I mean I was obviously
a fan of Destiny back in like 2022
in that era of Destiny, >> but I haven't been a fan of
him for years. Like that was like the last year that I really
kept watching him. I've been watching Destiny from like 2018
to like 2022.
And uh you know I was mostly a fan of his drama coverage. I didn't
really care about his politics. I just liked when he would cover
like Twitch dramas and stuff like that. I thought he I thought
he was good there, but uh that's pretty much it. I mean, he I
doubt he knows who I am. Like when he said like he mixes me and
Dioro up, I kind of believe that cuz I doubt he really knows
or remembers who I am. But yeah, I don't know. >> Maybe.
I just feel like you guys um are difficult to mix. Okay. >> Yeah,
that depends on how much he's paying attention to the commentary
community. I mean, we're pretty small fries in the grand scheme
of things. You know what I mean? >> I guess Dorio not much
anymore, but I'm certainly like I'm so like in and out of this
whole scene that like I don't I'm not surprised when somebody
says like they have no idea who I am cuz that makes sense to
me. >> I was more thinking just the idea that he doesn't
know who Nicholas is. That he doesn't know Nicholas is like his
own defined entity. That part does sound a little bit suspicious
to me cuz I think that they've talked at least a little bit enough
to where he should recognize >> Well, Nick is also just
like a massive YouTuber. Like he's getting like what four or
five thousand concurrent viewers at this point. >> Like
he's he's roughly he's pretty getting pretty close to like Destiny's
size and Vos's size. Well, now he is, but like when he was uh
when Nick was most active in the chat right now, when the stream
vastly improved, did JT talk included his girlfriend back into
the crazy internet drama that she did a great job having coverage
of it in a way that's totally mentally healthy for her? Hey,
Destiny, didn't you name doc your girlfriend by reading a Kiwi
Farms post on your stream the other day? >> That's crazy.
>> Didn't you just read her docs openly on your stream
and then you pretend that you actually care about her? Or wait,
is it ex-girlfriend now or is it current girlfriend? I forget.
>> Sounds like Destiny wants to call in, >> Apparently,
he wants to call in. >> Let's do it. >> Oh, wait.
Hold on. Did you see this one from earlier today? Not earlier
today. I guess it was yesterday. Someone asked Anaka Kasparian
why she doesn't want to debate Destiny. She said, "I think it's
because I read his DMs about how he likes to walk around in public
with a butt plug a few days a week, and I can't take him seriously
after that." I just think that's totally fair. Like, do you have
to take somebody's political opin opinion seriously if they have
to steal their wife's butt plug? They can't even get their own.
>> It's pretty weird. Pretty deranged, huh? >> That's
saying nothing of the weird diaper fetish.
>> Yeah, I want to get Destiny in here. Call in. But now
he's going to say like, "Oh, they're just begging for clout or
something like that." I mean, if you're going to type in the
chat, I feel like you should be able to mic up. You know what
I mean? >> You would think so. >> I wonder if he's
I don't know. He could be possibly. Let me make sure he's not
banned from the server
real quick. >> Oh, he's typing again. >> He's just
going to keep attacking Cherry because he's too much of a to
explain any of his own [__] He's not banned. No,
you can hop in. I'm sure. >> We're just talking about your
diaper fetish, Destiny. Your diaper fetish. >> Come on.
You don't be epic content. Get your ass in here. >> Oh,
he also responded to this by saying this isn't true. I would
love to know exactly how or why this isn't true. He watches the
content a lot, by the way. This is the second night this month
that he's been in here in chat.
>> That's crazy. >> He also chased me into like another
political streamer's Discord and started trying to harass me
in there.
It's very >> It's very mad. Very upset with you. >> Yeah.
But apparently I'm obsessed with >> I mean, is it this
like aren't you, No offense, but aren't you like small potatoes
compared to Destiny? I mean
>> You know, he's got like a million subs on YouTube and
stuff like that. It's kind of odd for him to monitor a kick
>> you know? >> Yeah. At what time is it in in Miami
right now? Is it 2 a.m.? >> It's 2 It's 2 a.m. right now.
And he's up at night watching your odd behavior. >> It
is. But hey, if he's around then I mean I don't know how you
feel about it. Me personally, it's like I feel like
I I mean I have questions for him. You know what I mean? So I
don't know. >> Uh I don't really have questions for him.
I just I just think it's funny that Anna Anna hits it directly,
right? That like this guy's too much of a weird freak to take
seriously. >> Yeah. Well, I just want to ask him for advice
like cuz you know I'm a new streamer. I just want to make sure
that I'm not coordinating with a bunch of doxers and swatters.
So, I just want a little bit of evidence, you know what I mean?
That you guys are worth doxing. I want to know like I want to
make sure that you guys aren't bad people to be >> I'm
sure he has that evidence somewhere. Did you see he he put a
a three-hour video saying Destiny It says Destiny clears his
name and it's him drawing in paint explaining how like information
goes from Kiwi Farms through like me and Quimman and then to
Bad Empanada and then to Hassan, I think. >> Oh, you mean
Kiwi Farms? That website that he loves. The website that he was
going to fund the defense of with Keles.
>> That website. >> The website with the thread on
Anna that he promoted
doxing it. >> The thread that doxes all of his friends
that he hates but also posts in and constantly taunts the the
main a logs in >> that thread. >> With the CEO that
he talked to on Tom stream and was chill with.
>> Very curious. >> Crazy. Destiny, why are you psycho
obsessed with Kosher Cathy? Dude, Destiny can come on right now
and kosher I'll unban Kosher Cathy from the Discord. Desi can
come on and debate Kosher Cathy right now.
Right now.
This could happen.
This was the This is the main person, okay? The main Discord
chatter that Destiny uses to prove that my my chat is unhinged.
Destiny can come and talk to him right now. I believe you met
Kosh or Kathy earlier tonight. Oh, is that the person that called
in? I was about to ask who that is. Is that the Indian person
that called into my chat? >> That's the very Yes, that
is the primary. That is the scariest defender in the J. >> They
were getting a lot of attention in my chat tonight just like
talking and I I figured that they were like a celebrity around
here or something like >> They're uh they're basically
just a troll and he he took the bait entirely and and that that
I believe they're a big part of his three-hour stream if I'm
not mistaken. Discord log person. Yeah, >> I can't talk
about him taking the bait. I mean, I [__] I was like,
"All right, call in." And then I talked to them and they're just
completely >> They're very funny. They're very funny.
>> Yeah. It was It was a good It was a good [__]
tonight. >> I don't think that he's going to come on. He
He's just He's not ready for it yet. I would love to go. >> He's
just giving you content. Oh, he's >> Yeah, he's just going
to keep trying to go after Cherry. I don't know. like he's just
obviously too scared to make any criticisms of me or you >> or
even you know provide proof provide any evidence of the kiwi
farm he >> He's going to keep trying to go after he's already
you have the chance to confront Nicholas Dioro right now. He's
here in call. >> He is here. >> Nicholas Dioro is
here right now >> Very big man just keeps attacking Cherry
instead of me who's the person him instead of Kelly who's the
person who his girlfriend. Nope. Doesn't go after any of these
people. He just goes after Cherry. He's busy snorting with a
plugin. Good lord. Is this going to be safe? Hold on. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Oh, hold on. It's good memes, too. Where is
this? Here. This is This went along with the uh the Anakasparian
tweet. Okay, I'm sorry that you have to see this. I'm sorry that
you had to see this. It is pretty That's going to be seared in
your chat's memory for a while. Wow. >> Absolutely horrifying.
It really is >> crazy, dude. I'm curious though. I want
to hear him I want to hear him speak for himself. You know, he
Destiny mentioned he's in war mode right now, right? He said
he's done ignoring you guys. He's ready to attack, right? I'm
genuinely curious like what he has to say. You know, it seems
like he's been preparing
all the propaganda. He's been preparing all the talking points.
You know, I'm ready to hear this play out in like a live VC.
>> He's running. He ran.
I Dude, I I can't help it, man. It's just how do I not How do
I not talk about this guy? He wants to show up all the time.
He's obsessed.
I did like four lines of coke for the first time in my life two
nights ago and I felt absolutely nothing. Wow.
Thank you for this. I don't know why this is I don't know why
this is important.
>> That is funny to think about. He just sits around here
and just watches this [__] while he like drifts off.
>> Dude, he is a Yeah, he's like um a millionaire. He could
be doing like whatever he wants. He's a millionaire in Miami
and he just hangs out here. The one night >> like some
insane like loser behavior. Like it's almost like unreal for
me to even think that >> he was at the last time he was
here. He's probably So I can tell you exactly what it is. Probably
Not so erodite is somewhere near him like in Miami and if he
wasn't here he'd have to be hanging out with her cuz the last
time he did this he was at an America event this thing where
he runs with not soite some other people and and yeah that was
his other option was he could have been hanging out with Arerite
and her husband or he could be in my chat like trying to talk
and of course we all know what he's going to pick there.
I I don't I Do you know much about erodite? Have you seen Arerodite
before? >> Know very little about her, but I mean I know
the basics, you know. >> That's like week three of Cabal
initiation. You'll you'll get a whole you get a whole like I
think there's 12 hours of like training courses on not so >> Not
soite. >> Yeah, it'll be like weeks. >> Well, I mean
I know that she's like a Destiny sick fan and she's pretty cringe,
but like I don't know the the details. Like what has she done
other than I mean I know she's like Jane Maxwell and that whole
meme.
>> Um that's the soundboard from her honestly. Nice. She's
she's like incredibly cringe. I I would say she used to just
be incredibly cringe. Now there's like some slight like she obviously
covers for this um predators degenerate and like I I think now
there's probably something to those chiseling Maxwell like claims.
Before I thought she was just so now I'm I'm starting to get
the impression she's malicious. I I kind of assume. No, no, I
won't go into any other theories, but I No, no, no. I'll I'll
message you or something. Can't make public allegations of things
I don't have proof of. You >> you know how it is. >> Time
to blueball the chat a little bit >> Yeah. Yeah. Unfortunately.
>> Crazy, dude. I'm intrigued now. >> Oh, I was just
going to I was just going to say I speculate. Okay. I speculate
with no evidence with no evidence whatsoever. So, don't take
it seriously that she's possibly the person who's been messaging
like Hutch, for example, who messaged Hutch and just said like,
"Hey, you shouldn't talk to this Queen guy. He's a weird he's
a weirdo. Don't talk to him." >> I I speculate. I speculate.
No, no real evidence. Okay. Going on with Quean and Hutch because
I know a little bit about Hutch. Like, is Queman been trying
to get a debate with him and Hutch is like, "This guy's insane."
Like, what's the story there? >> Yeah. So, Queeman had
some criticisms of Hutch. I think Hutch Hutch said some [__]
about like oh you know I'd probably forgive Destiny like five
years down the road I'd forgive Destiny or something right and
Queen was like this is like when you he he like went into Hutch
and also he really hated Hutch's um engagement with some there
was like some debate on have you heard of Lib and Learn there's
a podcast with a couple guys who used to be kind of in Desi's
political orbit called Lib and Learn it's like four dudes and
Hutch is one of them and on this podcast they had basically a
debate between each other about how much they should court like
Hassan types like very far-left, right, for their coalition,
their political coalition. And Queen really hated Hutch's arguments
for that. And so Quinn was criticizing this guy, went on to criticize
some of his like some of the things he said about Destiny or
something. And then I believe clips from that got posted on KF
and then somebody asked for I think his docs or something, right?
I think that was like the vague progression. Now, can Queen control
that that somebody gets mad about watching a Queen's stream,
post a clip, and no, right? He obviously can't control that,
but that that basically got blamed on him. So Hutch originally
agrees to a debate with Queenman when Queen's criticizing him
because Queen posts this like bald loser YouTube video, right?
And yeah, Hutch agrees to this debate. Then somebody messages
Hutch and Hutch pulls out of the debate. And then I believe he
might have re-engaged and said, "Okay, we'll debate you after
all." Cuz somebody else messaged Hutch. And then eventually the
thing with the the docs request got sent to him and he did actually
pull back all the way. I believe that's how it went. That seems
crazy because that that is like a good argument, right? Well,
not a good argument, but it's like it's more of an argument than
I've heard that Queen and you guys are like running like a doxing
community and stuff like that, right? How come that's not the
Willie Mack video? >> again, I'm not saying that's like
a good I'm not saying it's a good argument, but it's at least
something more to at least add to the narrative, right? >> Yeah.
Yeah, sure. Uh, I think that is like probably the closest thing
to evidence. But unfortunately, that's not like the whole picture.
That's like how they would paint it if I was going to like steelman
the way. But that's leaving out things, right? Destiny was also
all in on that drama and was clearly trying to drive a wedge
between Hutch and the other people on that show, that four-person
show. Like he was saying how they were being totally unfair to
him. Like it was totally unhinged and there's a whole drama that
happened with all of these people together, right? So Destiny
himself was really involved.
This whole thing about audience responsibility is just so ridiculous
to me because it's like it literally like gives like the the
the streamer like an impossible mission where it's like you cannot
be critical or harshly critical of somebody that because you're
so mean, somebody in your community might go awall and take it
way too far cuz people take [__] way too far all
the time. You as the streamer, >> you're the guy that establishes
how far things are allowed to be taken, right? Of course, the
audience is going to try to go further than where you draw the
line. And that's when you ban them or get rid of them or discourage
their behavior somehow, stuff like that, right? But you as the
streamer, like your job is just drawing the line.
That's what you do. You basically say like you guys are not allowed
to go further than where anywhere that I'm comfortable going.
That's how I've always viewed it. Right. >> Yeah. Yeah.
But I mean, >> if people do take it further, then you get
rid of them or you reprimand them or >> Yeah. Exactly.
So, as Tequila Sunset points out, and this was something I thought
about doing tonight. I don't think we're going to have time,
but I thought about going over the CEL's manifesto because realistically,
this is a massive part of what the CEL's manifesto was, right?
Ke's convinced a bunch of people that Destiny was like hate rating
her, was trying to like dox people around her, that he was tied
to Kiwi Farms, right? And uh Destiny presented the standard that
everybody else thinks is still the standard to this day is like,
well, here's what I can do. I can say what's allowed and not
allowed. I can ban the people who do what are not what's not
allowed. and you can report to me if they're doing something
that's not allowed and I will ban them. They're going and trying
to dox you somewhere and you have proof of this. I will ban them.
But like I I'm not omniresent. I can't do everything right. So
you have to let me know. And now he's basically gone and just
taken the Keel's position completely. >> Yep. I am curious
to see that. I mean it's a long ass stream but it is like worthy
of reviewing. You know what I mean? Like just seeing like how
those arguments like correspond to things today. It was also
like for Willie Mack like his war against Dark Viper, you know,
when Dark Viper saying stuff like the commentary community like
facilitated my docs being spread and stuff like that. I mean,
we all looked at that and was like, "Dude, you're insane."
I mean, there's like clips of Willie Mack talking about how ridiculous
that is that
>> you know, Dark Viper would ever try to like attribute
that crime to him and his community,
but now I'm seeing the same thing happen here. >> Yeah.
I see. I mean, and it's unfortunately Willy's case, it's the
exact same guy. Like, he literally made it's like, dude, do you
not understand? You were making an argument about principles
and now you've totally flipped and you don't give any reason
for why you flipped on this. Like, you went from laughing at
this guy saying it was insane for you to do this and now you're
just doing it and there's like no connection there. That's what
>> Yep. I think that's what makes it clear to me that unfortunately
and I I realize you probably don't want to go this far because
he's your friend, but it just seems really clear to me that he
doesn't he's never really written his own videos consistently.
He's never really been the person who's like the the thinker
behind his videos. And he kind of just posts like that he can
put together from other people cuz he he can't connect the concepts.
Like he didn't understand how embarrassing it was for him to
make this video, let alone post it. Like making it after the
videos he's already made, that's embarrassing. and then he posted
it publicly. So yeah, I don't know. It's possible you don't want
to go after him for that, but for me personally, I'm like, "Yeah,
it's very clear you have your videos ghost written." And we knew
that like we we know Doomer wrote some of his other videos, right?
We know that he had that >> you know Willie like when it
comes to like Willy's my friend or something like that. I mean
I don't really see what he's done recently as like friend behavior
personally like
>> he took some personal shots at me or whatever, right?
So it's like I don't really I mean I don't know. I'm kind of
like just soured on him as a person after this video, but >> I
don't know. It is what it is.
>> I'm probably going to uh check out of this stream and
rate into you or whatever. I'm I'm feeling pretty tired or whatever.
I've been live for a bit, but uh good talking, man. >> Yeah.
Yeah, >> good talking. >> Cool. Cool. Yeah, good
talking. And are you back to streaming more regularly or you
just going to still be you part-time in it for a while or
>> No, pretty much back to regular behavior. I mean, after
this, like, uh, it's regularly scheduled programming, you know,
just covering topics and the news and stuff like that. So, we'll
see what it we'll see what goes on. We'll see where this war,
you know, the commentary civil war, we'll see where it
how it continues. But, uh, yeah, I'm pretty much back to the
the full grind or whatever. So, uh, yeah, if you want to check
out my streams, I'll get on YouTube and kick.
>> Thanks for having me on, bro. >> Yeah, thanks
for coming on. Talk to you >> Hell yeah. See you. Oh, Cozer.
Too late.
Too late. If Auggie does see this at some point soon
here, I'll ask once he raids in. I'll ask him. I'll ask him for
you. Okay. Destiny understands all this. He's just weaponizing
his platform to smear you and anyone who criticizes Destiny will
be disregarded because you're all bad. It's just sad. Yeah, I
know. I know. I know. Wait. Uh, Koser, was there more stuff on
the right-wing egirl civil war stuff? Cuz I covered some of the
main, right? What? Oh, nice. Hold on one second. Sending sending
messages. Sending messages. Sorry, I might have uh more information
on stuff here in just a second. Okay.
Uh Auggie RFC with the raid. Thank you so much, Auggie. Welcome
Raiders. Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome. We are
We got a whole bunch of stuff left to do tonight. I believe we're
going to go over this Hutch stream of Hutch Hutch talking about
Quean and then probably we'll go through the Willy Mack interview
with Hutch. That's what we'll do. That's what we'll plan for
the rest of the stream. I'm going to hold off of anything else
other than that. I just wanted to point out that Willie Mack
is not not going on streams. So, contrary to popular belief,
okay, everybody's like, "Well, Willie Willie Mac's not really
going on streams anymore." >> Hutch, how's it going? >> That's
not true. >> What's up? Hey, what's up, Hutch? How's it
going?